Carlos Fuentes ha vivido la mayor parte
de su vida en silla de ruedas tras un
accidente que lo dejó cuadriplejico se
traslade en transporte público pero las
precarias condiciones del servicio y la
falta de infraestructura para personas
con discapacidad complican aún más su
movilización
no hay escaleras eléctricas operativas
este tengo que pedir ayuda
a algunos buenos samaritanos que pasen
para que me ayuden a bajar la escalera y
si por una mala suerte se llegan a caer
imagínense rodar por todas esas
escaleras en esta condición es terrible
desde 2007 en Venezuela está vigente la
ley para personas con discapacidad que
abarca derechos y garantías en materia
de Educación trabajo accesibilidad y
Transporte pero en la práctica no se
cumple Los afectados Como gisandra quien
perdió la mayor parte de su movilidad en
un accidente de tránsito denuncia que en
el país las personas con discapacidad no
tienen acceso al mercado laboral formal
si no trabajo independiente no tengo
este posibilidad de que alguien me
contrate pues una silla de ruedas por su
alto costo también resulta inaccesible
para la mayoría hay quienes como
lisandra han logrado adqui las gracias a
fundaciones privadas que reciben dinero
desde el exterior hemos entregado 10.000
y pico de sillas y santificando la
cuenta el otro día nos daba una silla
por día que suena tonto pero no no es
bien complicado el pasado mes de julio
el parlamento venezolano aprobó en
primera discusión un proyecto de ley
para garantizar la inclusión laboral y
la adecuación de los espacios de trabajo
para personas con discapacidad la
Organización Mundial de la Salud estima
que en Venezuela y cerca de cuatro
millones y medio de personas con algún
tipo de discapacidad sin embargo el
último censo oficial hecho en el país
fue en el 2011 la falta de estadísticas
dificulta la atención de esta población